if you have a woman [ __ ] four Dudes
you don't even know who who are pregnant
so may I just disgusted wait wait have
you seen the twins that had two
different dads oh oh yeah I saw that may
I just say something then so if that is
the case yeah if the one thing that
you're meant to have is you at least you
know who the two people that put that
child on Earth are then that's why
promiscuity for men is also a problem
because they get women pregnant
sometimes they don't even know they have
children that's a run no no it's
completely different it's different
because you have to understand I'm
talking about humans you look at humans
from a societal perspective but Society
has changed right so let's say two 300
years ago if a woman got pregnant she
needed a man to survive if that man
didn't take care of her during pregnancy
she was going to die she couldn't work a
job she couldn't hunt couldn't fish
whatever right a woman literally needed
that man for survival so if if you were
to come to me and say I'm pregnant but
you've been [ __ ] by four different
dudes I'm like who says it's mine why am
I looking after you